well if social media had not put its
thumb on the scale in the middle of this
election donald trump
would likely be a runaway favorite to to
win the election as it is
it is still not over he very well could
end up as president but social media has
played a heavy role in restricting what
people can see
and what people can hear and they are
continuing to do so even as president
trump
tweets about the situation at the ballot
boxes across the country even as he
tweets
about the possibility of voter
irregularities he is being censored not
just
it's not just trump our own matt walsh
here at the daily wire host of the matt
wall show
he had the temerity to tweet something
out that was then censored by twitter
it happened to be correct matt thanks so
much for joining the show
hey thanks for having me so why don't
you lay out the story for us what you
tweeted and then what president trump
retweeted and then
how you ended up in the crosshairs of a
twitter's censorship brigade
yeah there was uh there was some someone
tweeted there had been reports about
about uh large amounts of ballots that
sort of appeared and all were going for
for for uh joe biden and none for donald
trump it was like a hundred thousand
plus
ballots or something like that 100
percent for biden none for
for trump um this was tweeted i
i retweeted it and added my comment that
i this is concerning you know we need to
look into this and and be concerned
about this and then trump
retweeted it as well uh and next thing
you know they
censor my tweet which means it's still
there but it means
you have to click take a couple steps to
get to it and they have all these kinds
of warnings and red flags
look out it might be misinformation now
i'm not sure how an opinion can be
misinformation i have never quite
understood this from twitter
if i'm giving my opinion what am i am i
misinforming people of my opinions
because that's that's
what it was um and uh and then it turns
out that
yeah there was there was a now it turns
out this was this was not an example of
frauds puzzling but this was an example
of a mistake that was made decimal point
was put in the wrong place or something
that that's what they're telling us well
the point is
there something concerning did happen
there was something weird that happened
and on twitter on social media we were
talking about it people were reporting
it
and we should be able to do that
especially during an election when
people want to know what's happening and
everything's delayed so
but twitter is uh is playing the role of
kind of
editor-in-chief and saying these are
these are not opinions that we want
expressed on our on our platform and you
know i don't think they should be able
to do that yeah it is pretty amazing how
social media have really cracked down on
all of this the reports in the last few
minutes
and there's a group on facebook called
stop the steal and the basic idea is uh
that you are going to monitor election
fraud there are hundreds of thousands of
members people who are
attempting to uh presumably weigh in to
stop election fraud and apparently
this is bad so facebook simply shut it
down yeah it is incredible to see how
social media have really as i say put
their thumb
on the scale here you've been ranting
about this uh for a while
so this battle is going to outlast this
election cycle
obviously what do you think are the
steps that ought to be taken here with
regard to social media at this point
well i think uh you know i'm i'm i'm
always skeptical i'm like one of those
conservatives i'm always skeptical about
getting government involved and that
sort of thing but
i think we're we're at a point where the
the easy answer the
the usual conservative answer of well
free let the free market take care of it
i think we're beyond that that's there
is no free market solution
to the social media monopoly facebook
and twitter
i mean unless someone's got a hundred
billion dollars laying around where they
want to start their own facebook or
their own twitter
uh but aside from that it's not gonna
happen and uh
and they they do exercise a lot of power
uh to manipulate and to sway our
elections this used to be something that
that
liberals pretended to be concerned about
and they seem to be less concerned about
it now all of a sudden because it's
going in their favor
um so i i think there is a role for the
government to step and i also think
at the very least these these companies
should be honest about what they are the
service they provide
if they have an ideological bent that
they're that they're trying to promote
if they have certain a certain ideology
a certain opinion that they
want to promote on their platform they
should have to be honest about that and
tell people about it at a minimum
i think that should be the case but
probably we can go further than that
we're streaming matt walsh host of the
matt walsh show over at daily wire okay
so matt what are your overall
impressions
of of how the election went uh i have to
say i'm feeling pretty good about the
election pretty optimistic about the
election
uh even putting aside the presidential
which again we are still waiting to see
what exactly happens here
the president's got lawyers on the
ground pretty much everywhere and
observers everywhere there are a bunch
of lawsuits being filed
all of that is going to get hashed out
and hopefully the system ends up making
proper decisions
and all that and we'll keep putting our
focus there but overall
i think that if you're a conservative
you have to be pretty happy with the
results given the fact that republicans
apparently picked up 100
seats in state legislatures across the
country didn't lose a single state house
across the country picked up
all this all the levers of power in in
new hampshire in the state legislatures
uh the the the republicans it looks like
they're probably gonna hold the senate
uh they picked up seven to 13 seats in
the house minimum i mean that that's a
good night for republicans
yeah i think so i mean taking the
presidential election out of it
completely which
we can't really do but when it comes to
the down ballot stuff i think that
there is a it would be hard not to feel
even if you're as passionate as i am
it'll be hard not to feel happy about
about that and it's uh
it kind of shows that democrats you know
this is
they're not speaking to the real issues
that
people care about the normal people care
about they have a they have a very
specific
radical left coalition that they've been
trying to appeal to especially in the
last few years and it's been slow for
decades but
especially in the last few years and i
think they're starting to
to see the results of that now whether
they learn the right lessons i think is
very much up in the air i mean if you
look at some of the chat on social media
and leftists and analysts and pundits
what they're saying i mean the the
lessons they're taking from it
from what i've seen is that america's
racist and minorities are going to trump
because there are self-hating minorities
or
you know toxic masculinity among black
men i mean these are the kinds of things
you're hearing from the left
so they're of course learning all the
wrong lessons um which i guess is good
for republicans because it means that
they'll keep losing
yeah i mean that is the good news for
republicans i think that that democratic
coalition is getting more and more
fractious and i think that it is going
to fracture i think one of the reasons
you saw
such a big spike in the latino vote for
republicans particularly in florida and
texas
is that democrats decided that they were
going to embrace socialism which is that
what many latinos
and hispanics were attempting to avoid
by coming to the united states in the
first place they've decided they're
going to embrace black lives matter and
proclaim
that all minorities in the country were
incapable of succeeding which is just
something that
a huge number of minorities disagree
with there's also this misimpression
in in liberal white circles that what
black people really want to hear is that
riots and lootings are good which is
such a bizarre
idea the people who suffer most in those
situations are law abiding black folks
which is most black americans
yeah and that's why that's why i talk
about the with the democrats they've
they've kind of conflated
black lives matter the organization with
the demographic group that black lives
matter
supposedly represents but that's not the
same thing and if you look at what black
lives matter actually believes in you
know of course
they've changed they've scrubbed their
website recently to make themselves a
little bit more appealing
to the to the general public but up
until that if you looked at what they
the kinds of things they talk about you
know hetero
they're they're trying to defeat
heteronormative thinking and to
dismantle the nuclear family and
you know they're very they're very
focused on things like trans rights
really black lives matter is
if more than anything it seems to mainly
be focused on gay rights it's really
more of like a gay rights organization
at least if you look at the issues that
they talk about on their own website
this is very little to do with just the
average black family or the average
white family
family of anyways but that's how that's
how the democrats
they've decided that if you're a racial
minor if you're a black person it means
that you are
a far left radical and we're gonna we're
gonna speak to you on that level
and surprise surprise it doesn't really
work that's matt walsh with matt while
show tune in over at dailywire.com
become a subscriber over there to get
more of matt matt appreciate the time
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content